um so a lot of people don't think about
inferential issues they think about pack
and learning and all that
it's just not there but there's this
other thing called statistics which has
a broad collection of ideas
and one of the broadest is the selective
inference problem the
family-wise error rate problem it's one
of the big problems of statistics
and some of the best most important
progress has been made over the last two
decades in this particular topic
uh and one of the leaders if not the
leader in that topic is
joel yamini and i'm just gonna without
any further ado turn over to him against
thank you
thank you thank you for the opportunity
uh to speak at this occasion the
opportunity to return to
berkeley for a visit which i do often uh
let me start but uh two apologies
first of all this apostrophe shouldn't
be there
so that's one thing the second thing is
that my hearing is not good so when you
ask me something
please speak up okay so even though i
have all the right aids i don't hear you
well
and the third thing uh did you
distribute the syllabus for this talk
no no that's good because i'm not
committed
to anything that i have to talk about
and i prepared a lot but if i'm not
covering it
that's fine that is we'll do it at the
right pace and don't be afraid to ask to
stop and so on if i feel that
it helps us i'll tell you okay
so i'm going to speak about first of all
about the whole idea of simultaneous and
selective inference
and then talk about uh testing with
false discovery rate this is sort of the
more basic part and that will be about
the first uh
half of the talk and then i'll talk
about false coverage wage estimation and
the connection to model selection ideas
and to more complex uh current research
problems and
actually i would like to start with what
i think is the first data mining problem
in statistics
and maybe even in science at large
and this is the kind of experiment uh
reported by steele and tory
in the 1960s and they go back to the
work of
erdemang who is an agriculture
researcher
and he was according to them he was
dealing with six groups of red clover
plants
each inoculated with a different strain
of resorbium bacteria
just in order to increase the nitrogen
content
and there were five measurements of
nitrogen content on each group
and uh we can certainly model it by the
average
the estimator in the group being
normally distributed with some min view
and standard error of sigma square over
5 because of the five measurements and
we have six groups
the reason i bring this here is that
this is the most
standard example of the kind of problem
that i'm going to show you
and it is quoted and it is both brought
up in
in the sas book explained the material
in bmdp and many textbooks and so on
really the
sort of a standard example in this
setting
what are we interested in this case
well you want to know the differences
between the groups
so you can estimate the difference by
comparing the
average or the mean the average in one
group minus the average in another group
then you want to know whether the
statistic is significant
so you set up the null hypothesis that
there is no difference between the
parameters
and you can do a two-sample t-test or
two-sample z-test if you know the sigma
squared
and so on in order to decide whether
this difference
is above what's expected under the noise
in the data and so you can
reject the null hypothesis in this case
or you can do it by a calculation of a
p-value that is you calculate
what is the probability if this is in
this the case
that the standard random variable would
be bigger than this difference
appropriately appropriately standardized
that this
is supposed under the null hypothesis to
be normal 0 1.
you calculate this one and this is the
p-value
and if the null hypothesis is true the
p-value
has to have a uniform distribution
over 0 1. so
once you have calculated the p-value in
order to reject h-f-s
you can reject h-naught and
you will do it in producing a type 1 l
only with probability less or equal to
alpha so this is the standard setting
of hypothesis testing either in this
form or in the sense of the p-value form
okay uh in the language of
this talk we will say that we will make
a discovery
with the probability to make a false
discovery that is the null hypothesis is
true but we are
deciding on that the difference exists
with the probability
less or equal to alpha
and we'll reject if the p value is small
enough that's the regular things
now why do i call it the first data
mining problem in statistics
because in this kind of problem besides
time we might
select the most promising groups
difference that is we'll take the
we have k groups we'll take the largest
average minus the smallest average
and we'll look whether these two are
statistically significant whether we
this above the
noise variation but with uh six times
five
over two different possible pairs that i
can compare
then even if i do each one at level
alpha
if i take the probability of the largest
minus the smallest
and divided by the appropriate thing
that will clearly be
less than alpha so even if the null
hypothesis is true there is no
difference between those groups
whatsoever just taking the largest minus
the smallest
will give me something which is biased
too often
will i get a false discovery
and of course the larger k the more
groups there are the worse the situation
is
well indeed when we going back we tried
and
were able to find the original paper by
the agricultural researcher
and he had 13 groups so we had 13 times
12
divided by 2 78 pairwise comparison
and with the limiting power of the 50s
actually of the 40s
this was a data mining problem that is
you had to calculate only 13 numbers
but the influence problem became huge
and suddenly
questions like do i keep what i do on a
single comparison
do they keep the properties when i'm
moving to a large problem
became relevant even at that age
so that's why i call it the first data
mining
problem in science and this is really
the
origin of the multiple comparison
problem
area or is it called mcp multiple
comparison problem
and and in fact the area
flourished during the 50s making the
some of the basic ideas that i'll
present
in the first few slides are from that
era
now let me demonstrate uh just what
what kind of problem do we have with
this kind of uh
with this kind of phenomenon this is
taken from the significant thing so
scientists study rumors eating colored
jelly beans causes acne
okay so there was
a study of purple jelly beans and in
fact
they don't seem to cause acne because
the p-value is bigger
than 0.05 and scientists studies where
the red ones
are and in fact they do not because it
is bigger than 0.05
no significant evidence and so on and
jelly
and then comes the green ones oh we
found a link between green jelly beans
and acne the p-value is less than 0.05
wow okay let's continue and continue
and continue and finish our study and
there comes the news green jelly beans
link to acne
95 confidence there is only five percent
chance of coincidence
this is the essence of selective
influence
you select out of the many things that
you looked at you select something that
looks
promising interesting something like
that
okay that's a cartoon but it's not only
jelly beans
this from a study data mining petition
at kegel
a unusual secrets are hidden in numbers
for instance
an orange car is less likely to have
serious damages that are discovered only
after
purchase that's exactly the same study
with exactly the same phenomena but here
it is
okay so we are still uh by the way there
is an explanation for that
of course okay
uh because those are very unusual cars
and people keep good track of their uh
they take good care of them and keep
them up in garages and give them usual
service and so on and so forth so there
was also an explanation
of why this happens
it's not only colors and jelly beans and
so on
giovanni and and others in the 95
examined the possible effects of excess
eating of 130
different kinds of foods on prostate
cancer
and there were three kinds of food that
cleared the statistical significance bar
and these are the only ones reported in
the article
abstract and the conclusion
was eat ketchup and pizza to prevent
prostate cancer
and the reason i encountered the reason
i encountered this
uh study is that i came to visit my
uh my friend and she is a very
food conscious person and she
offered me a pizza for the first time in
my life and i said what's that vita
and she said oh it's good for your
prosthetic cancer and that's how i found
about this
about this one now
unfortunately in the article itself all
130 results are there
i mean there's no writing there's no
mischief in that
everything is reported but the abstract
carries
this information only and the abstract
information the abstract is the
selection process
by which the interesting finding the
significant findings
are protein are passed to the public and
in fact even to professionals
i mean ask your colleagues or friends
who are physicians whether they read the
paper or they read the abstracts
okay the answer is think is clear
now uh just as a for curiosity i checked
uh
a year ago what situation with this kind
of study
uh there were about one it cited over
1000 times dozens of studies about the
contribution of tomatoes
to the healing of different types of
cancers with unclear results
uncle results here results in this
direction the other direction
the most recent study that i've seen at
that time claims that the secret is in
the organelle
and it was published in tv before it was
even presented in a conference
so that's the nature of significant
findings so what is our first line of
protections against this phenomena well
since the danger seems largest when all
of the
difference i'm going back to the
original question of this pairwise
comparison
since the question seems the most severe
when all the muse are the same
because then you have the most of the
most possibilities to have a type 1
error
then test this hypothesis that they are
all the same
and you can do it via f test at level
alpha
uh those of you don't know what an f
test doesn't matter but it tests just
this single hypothesis
and if it's not significant stop
that's the first line of petition but if
it's significant continue and do all
pairwise comparison as we did before
this is called actually it's a
suggestion by fischer it's called the
fischer
uh turkey gave it the name fischer uh
protected
lsd uh not because of the material
because he treated it is the least
significant difference that one
can think of now why is it that this
significant difference can you see
was the problem with this first line of
protection
well suppose one of the muse is far away
from the rest of them you are
about to reject this first line of
protection
now you have with the problem which does
instead of k things in the same place
k minus one things in the same place
just a very little bit less of a problem
but mostly everything is just the same
so if we want to uh
so this kind of protection was given the
name
family's error rate in the weak sense
that is if you manage to control just
this probability
this is called the family-wise error
rate in the weak sense
that is that the null hypothesis that
everything is equal
the probability of making even one type
one error
is less or equal to alpha
now at this point i need some attention
in order to continue
we are talking the problem right now
about
testing many hypotheses so you have h1
to hm
and not of the m hypothesis tested are
true
meaning that we have only m minus m not
which
are false meaning m minus m not
potential real
potential discoveries all the rest are
if we discover them are in error
now we do not know which ones
are the full are the true ones or the
false one we don't know their numbers
and at some point of time though we'll
try to
estimate this number at some point of
time but
generally we just assume that the result
of any testing procedure is r i
uh r i equals one if h i is rejected if
a discovery was
made zero otherwise and with vi
we uh measure whether uh
whether an error was made whether we
rejected but
h i is true that is we made the type one
error
or we made a false discovery and it is
defined as
zero otherwise overall we look at all
the number of the hypothesis rejected
out of the m that will be
r and the number of hypotheses rejected
in error
is v so the weak family wise error rate
that we defined before
is really the probability that the
number of errors will be greater or
bigger than one
so that's just a formulation of what we
said so far
now the second line of protection okay
since this is not enough
we want to protect against any
configuration the muse can be
one far away and all the rest together
they can be
at two groups and uh in each one m over
two things are
mused together we want to protect again
any possible configuration
and not to make even one error when we
make inference the many inference
so the family-wise error rate is the
probability of
making one or more errors in our
study so by assuring
having a method that assures that family
wise error rate is less or equal to
alpha the probability of making
even one type one error in the family is
controlled at level alpha
and this is also called as the
terminology of being called the
simultaneous inference
that is all inferences we're going to
make about all the ma
the m hypothesis are going to hold
jointly we're not allowing even one
error
in our body of influences
the same is true when we are trying to
put confidence interval confidence is
well we're trying to put
we have a quantity like estimating the
difference and we want to put a
confidence interval that states that
you know with a high probability of say
0.95
it will cover the true unknown value of
the parameter that might
give us information about the size you
can similarly define
v to be the number of intervals failing
to cover
the respective parameter and if you have
for any configuration of the parameters
the probability that even one of them
will fail to cover less or equal to
alpha
the such of such interval is called to
have
simultaneous coverage level one minus
alpha
okay this is clearly a protection i mean
we've got it
nice and i will
take the brother and discuss the old and
trusted solutions because some of them
are so
oddly presented that it worth emphasis
so what what happens if we test each
hypothesis separately at level
alpha bond some level alpha
okay and i look at the expected number
of errors
the expected number of errors that i
make is the expected of the sum of the
vi
each one measuring an error in a
particular hypothesis
the sum of expectation of the sum is the
sum of the expectation
and this is less or equal to m naught
times the level at which
i'm doing each test because v i is a
zero one
random variable okay m naught is the
number of two null hypothesis is certain
less than or equal to the number of
hypotheses i
test so this one is n times alpha bond
so if we want to assure that the
expected number of errors that we make
is less or equal to alpha
we may use alpha bond cerony which is
alpha over m
and this is the famous bonferroni method
did we need any condition here
no condition of the distribution nothing
at all unfortunately
the bonferroni is often referred to as
something that holds only under
independence and that appears in
textbooks
so that's why i'm i'm making here an
effort to convince you that it is a
simple property
hardly any inequality involves just the
expectation of the sum is the sum of the
expectation
and that's and that's and that's it
and so we have that it controls under
any configuration the expected number of
errors is less equal to alpha
well i didn't talk about the expected
number of errors i talked about the
probability of making even one error
before that the family-wise error rate
well
this way it also ensures that the
probability that v will be bigger or
equal to one at level alpha
and that's because the simple thing that
the expectation of v is zero times the
probability that
number of errors will be zero plus one
times the probability that it would be
one plus two times
that it would you will have two errors
and so on and so forth
but we can always reduce it this one
will be zero we reduce this one to one
reduce this one to one reduce this one
we
run and we have the probability that v
is
bigger or equal to 1. so if we use
alpha bonferroni for each individual
test
or for each confidence interval we make
it a level alpha over m
the family-wise error rate is
at less or equal than the expected
number of errors and therefore that's or
equal to alpha
okay this is uh sort of the first
method that was inverted now there was
no condition here
can we gain if we introduce some strong
condition for example
uh something about the distribution of
the testing so
we can say that what happens if the test
statistics are independent
because if they're independent i i don't
i can actually calculate probabilities
so if the test statistics are
independent and we test each hypothesis
separately at some level alpha sid
then the probability of making even one
error is one of minus the probability of
making
no error this is one minus alpha
one minus alpha c to the power of m
naught
sorry which is this less or equal to
raising it to the power of m which is
less or equal to alpha so if we want
this one we simply have to take the
alpha level for each test at one minus
one minus alpha
to the power of 1 minus m and this is
sydux multiple testing procedures
and note that if m naught equals m then
we have here equalities all the way so
in some sense it is
the best that you can gain
okay so we use the dependency structure
in this case to get a better test
how much better surprisingly not that
much
that is alpha c is one to the power of
one minus alpha one over
m which is approximately one minus alpha
over m
uh with the squared uh taylor and so we
have alpha bonferroni
alpha over m plus something which is the
order of alpha square
and divided by m times n minus one so
the larger m
is really the advantage was disappeared
even for small
m okay there is very little gain if we
do the bonferroni we do 0.05005
if we use the see that 0.0511
okay so this is the amount that we gain
some situation like the one i started
with the pairwise comparison
we can gain more from utilizing the fact
i mean
remember if you do uh group one minus
group two group two minus group three
there is very strong correlation between
the two
correlation is positive uh in this case
will be negative
group one one is group two group one one
is group three
the correlation will be positive okay
took this procedure for pairwise
comparison
utilize the dependency by calculating
the distribution
of the maximum of this one that is the
largest
minus the smallest average when they're
all normally and independent but
once you take the differences there is
this structure it's the same idea as was
here
but a larger gain and interestingly this
is known as a post
yeah i have a question so if you use
this
um
um will it affect the number of tattoo
errors you may have
the effect though the the the number of
type 2
errors because we're just talking about
type 1 areas right
so if i reduce you know i i replace my
alpha with f
over m does that affect the type two
maybe the probability of
making a finding yes yeah the power
obviously okay
obviously that's why there is there is a
strong balance and the hesitation of
many people to admit that they have this
problem
because it harms the power tremendously
and i'll demonstrate this point
i'll demonstrate this point okay
so this is known as post talk analysis
again this is another name that is given
to data mining data mining
is post hoc analysis of your data the
point is that you look at the data
and then you select in view of the data
what to infer upon that that's what the
point is
in all those examples
last one in this uh in this point
uh newer solution well newer should
receive some qualifications from 79
but it's much newer than the other ones
and i will use it later on
if we look at the p values each p
value for each hypothesis and we order
the p values for smallest to the largest
so this is the smallest one second
smallest and so on this is the largest p
value of the m of them now we compare p1
to alpha over m
a bonferroni type of thing if it passes
that is if it is rejected we look at the
second one but compare it to alpha
over m minus one the idea i mean
we are sure that one is okay so now we
have to protect against
n minus one hypothesis so we can do it
with l alpha minus one and so on and so
on we continue
until for the first time we cannot
reject and we have to stop at this point
even if
even if on later on there are some
things like that
and it's interesting to know that it
always controlled the family-wise error
rate
in spite of this sort of greedy method
that we are doing
it it always control the families wider
again
no strings attached no distributional
assumption nothing at all
the only problem you can't make
confidence interval with this kind of
thing
that's uh okay
let me give you an example an example
from my own research
so uh i'm also i've been involved over
the years with research with
mice behavior and genetics of mice
behavior and so on and so forth
and what i will show you now is the film
of a mouse in our laboratory
exploring a new arena
sorry
so what you see here is the mouse
getting out of the hole and exploring
and going back to the hole
goes out notice that he makes stops and
then moves again
moves again then he goes back to the
origin
he goes a little bit away from the wall
goes in the other direction makes stops
and other stops goes back here
then comes another excursion outside
into the white wood
you will go all the way here make
another one here
and go back to the hole and this kind of
extremely structured behavior
we managed to measure it to quantify it
and and really to study the its growth
and so on because it will go on like
that
and it may go on like that and return
back home
and then suddenly he will realize that
it's the same thing
and he will make a few rounds like that
very happily running around the arena
and then he will start to explore the
center
okay what i'm going to use this example
is to demonstrate use of the p-values
and
different methods and this is the result
of
a large phenotyping effort
done in three laboratories at tel aviv
university
nida and nprc okay so you have here
different behavioral endpoints like uh
the number of progression segment each
time that he gets out of here the time
away from the wall
our distance traveled the number of
excursions that you have seen
with all kind of quantification of the
behavior in this case 17 different
measures
we can tell them about across
laboratories with the mixed smaller
and here are the p values and they're
already sorted
from the smallest p-value to the largest
p-value
and if i use an unadjusted
okay if i use the regular
think i would declare all of this to be
statistically significant i have a lot
of findings in terms of the difference
oh this is done between eight strains of
mice and so i want to know
is there a genetic factor in this kind
of behavior
but if i take the bonferroni one
all i get is the 0.0002 line
well that's a big difference and that's
the point that you were
you were making a big difference between
using the unadjusted
one and protecting against the effect of
selection in this form
and that's really the reason why many
people
try to avoid it until they have to so
for instance the fda
drug approval requires very strict
adherence to the multiplicity issue
to protect you in some way against this
kind of
selective influence what happens in this
example
in the search for food affecting
prostate cancer these three
food intakes that we're reducing if you
use the bonferroni
they do not come out significant all
right sorry if you
if you use the donferoni you they do not
come up significant if you don't use the
von fernie well those are the three
that made themselves to the article so
again there is a
an important difference between uh
between the two
now with current research the problem
becomes
more and more severe i want to give an
example i'll return to it at the end of
my talk
if i get to it if not not and this is
from our
recent research uh
trying to find association between brain
volume
and different parts of the brain and um
and the genetic background
and this is based on the alzheimer's
disease neuroimaging initiative
and so the goal is to determine
biological markers for alzheimer's
disease by testing for association
between volume changes and voxel with
genotype
so you bring the brains of the people
that are scanned
by mri you bring them to a common
framework and so you can change
you can check at each voxel volume pixel
in the brain that division of that what
what would be the change and associate
it with a genetic marker a snip that can
take
two possible values and three possible
values
a a um bb and
a b this is the way that the original
article reports it
you see this uh these are five
particular snips for each one of them
the number of voxels volume volume
pixels in the brain
that are searched for 32 000 what you
see are just
the few slices but there are more slices
they are just not brought out
so there are 32 000 voxels searched
there is number of snips
is four thousand about four thousand to
four hundred
sorry four hundred and forty thousand
snips along this dimension of course you
see only the first five
so we are talking here about 13
billion tests of association
done and the original paper
brings this one as an example this is
clearly
a very strong selection from the pool of
result that you have
and it is clear that it has to be
adjusted
for this strong selection and in fact it
does in
in neural imaging it is very customary
to address this problem usually to the
problem of 32 000
this is really a different dimension
a totally different dimension and needs
different methods
now what is the common point in large
application that was demonstrated by
this
figures that i showed in these launch
problems
the selected ones are presented are
highlighted
are discussed the strength is displayed
the effect estimated articulated and so
on and so forth
but those that are not selected are
completely ignored you don't know even
what they were
they're not given name in the good
situation like the 100 foots they are
somewhere in the table in the paper
sometimes they are buried in other
examples they are buried into
supplementary
or in a database that if you wish you
can go and look at it
sometimes even that is not simply there
is a clear distinction
between those that are selected and
those that are not selected
okay and not selected i mean they're
just
ignored now
my point is that increasing the scale
changes the goal and
the best evidence that we have is from
tuki's own
work in 1978
remember took his procedures from the
50s in 1978
in the discussion paper would one should
always control the family-wise error
rate
okay i mean there's a clear statement
that it's important in
scientific and in other words to control
this one
well in 1994 he was asked to consult on
the national assessment educational
progress here in the states
comparing the results of the national
as a test uh between the states
now 35 states participated in that so
the number of comparisons was 595.
now even took his correction is huge
in this case and this was a project that
nice
and there was a debate how to report the
results do you report them
as they come or do you make some kind of
adjustment to take care of the
possible selection and in fact
at that time that was 94 tukey was one
of the first aware of our work on the
false election
false discovery rate and the solution
was to use the false discovery rate
approach which i will
discuss in a minute so
it's the size of the problems and the
loss of power that you mentioned that
come with it
that really made it necessary to try to
some sense to address the selection
problem but
try not to lose as much power as it's
done
so what about testing with fdr control
the false discovery rate criteria uh we
defined before the number of rejected
hypothesis let's call them the number of
discoveries the number of false
discoveries
this the joint work uh of me with
josie hofberg started in 89 a piece in
95. now we look at the type 1 error in
the entire study and not by the
number of errors but the relative number
of errors that is
we look at the proportion of folks
discovery
among the discoveries v over r the
proportion of them
and put it at zero if nothing was
rejected
and defined the false discovery rate to
be the expected value of this proportion
that that's that's the difference point
of view
let me discuss for quickly why does it
make sense
if i inspect 100 features and we get two
false ones among 50 discovered
verbal it's statistics i mean we're
ready even if we do one hypothesis we're
ready to bear some error
i mean we can't otherwise we will not
make any conclusion if we are not ready
to bear
so 2 out of 50 is fine but two false one
out of four
well that's too much to bear so
in that sense uh i do not decide
beforehand whether two
is good or two is bad it is adaptive to
the situation i'm facing
the same argument holds when i test
ten thousand features i'm looking at the
discoveries not at the number
so in that sense it is scalable in the
computer science uh
notion of it and uh
if nothing is real that is if all the
150 or 10 000 features are all false
then the probability of making even one
error is exactly the same as the
expected value of this proportion
because if everything is false v equals
r
always everything that i reject is an
error so this one it takes the value 1
if i reject something and zero if i
don't
its expectation is exactly the
probability
that i will make even one error so i
have this weak
protection first line of protection is
satisfied but then i go on
beyond that because otherwise since here
have a
random variable which was values is less
so it is less or equal to one
can be strictly less than one clearly
this one
the fdr is less or equal to this
probability so if i
control this one at alpha i'm giving up
on this protection
so i can gain more power
so let me summarize simultaneous
inference infrastructure
jointly for all parameters this kind
that i presented selected
inference infants should hold for the
selected parameters
the same way it holds for each parameter
separately
okay but on the average over the
selected
okay so if i have for a single
confidence interval
the problem the expected value that it
covers or not covers is 0.95
i want it to have on the average over
the selected
the same kind of thing and doing each
one
separately at the level alpha or
confidence interval at the level of
0.95 is not enough because
if i look at the expected number of
errors divided by the number of
tests performed that is e of v divided
by the number of tests performed
this will be less or equal to alpha if i
don't
do anything while fdr control ensures
that i divide this by the number of
tests selected by the number of
rejections that i make
and this is now this
statement will repeat itself again and
again during my talk this is hindsight
we didn't have this insight when we
designed the full discovery rate
in fact our original motivation was a
paper by zorch
a physician by training arguing that
most research discoveries might be false
when using the regular 0.05 level
and this was the motivation to
use the term discovery and so on and
this was the term of motivation in fact
the famous paper by ionidis that has
made news again and again how many
people
are aware of that quite a few this is
exactly the same as this one the same
argument
in this one as in the and this
storage one
okay the question is can we offer a
controlling procedure in this case
well interestingly uh we can and this is
the
uh the one that we gave and i'll work
with
elsie hoffler and my work with drc hope
is the b8
now called bh linear step-up procedure
we called it and again we sort the
p-values as we did for the whole
procedure from the smallest to the
largest
and we take k to be the maximum i such
the eighth p value
is less or equal to i over m times q we
stop
at the largest one such thing and we
reject all hypotheses
uh sometimes mathematics is too
complicated so the formula is
uh is a formula but the procedure is
very simple and can be done in like
excel spreadsheet i mean you order the p
values as well then before
you compare the largest one with 0.05
times 17 over 17.
looking at the 17 p-value if this one is
less than this one then fine but it is
not
okay so we look at the second one we
compare it to 0.05 16 over 17
it is not and how about the 15 over 17
times 0.05 this is still
not less than that and so we continue
all the way up and the first time that
this happens
is here we have your 0.0257 and 0.0265
so from here we don't look at that we
just reject it
again another thing that is often
overlooked we don't look at what happens
here
okay so uh the fact that uh
this one is bigger than that doesn't
matter just stop here
now see what kind of compromise we got
remember this was the value that we did
by unadjusted testing
that was the value that we could get by
bonferroni adjustment
what it means that there is a strong
indication that there are many
true signals here and therefore we don't
have to be
that conservative in our appreciation of
what is significant and what
is not and we can stop here
that's a graphical another graphical way
to look at it we sort the p-values
and the constraint is linear i over
m times 0.05 in this case is simply the
linear line
and we look at the first time that we
have a point dropping below the line
a third way to look at it is using
adjusted p-value
since they have a special name in this
case i will
put it we looked at this procedure
right we compare pi to i over n times q
well move the m here and the i here you
have here m times
p i divided by i look at that that's
really the
if we reject with p i as a threshold
the expected number of errors we make is
mpi
how many did we reject well i because we
are going to reject everything that is
smaller than that
well that's sort of an intuitive
assessment of the false discovery
proportion
the expectation expected number of
errors divided by the number of feet
well we greedily just take and make this
comparison take the largest one
and uh and that's equivalent to
to this one and this one can define the
beach adjusted p
values and that's called also q values
uh my stories terminology
and they are simply the maximum j over o
j bigger than i
that i look at this thing and when i do
that
i can reject h i if it's adjusted p
value is less or equal to the
derived clue so it they serve exactly
the role of a p
value and you can put them instead of p
value so you have the p
values and you can have an adjusted ph
now that's important because we will
have
other methods of of that offer false
discovery rate so
it should come with um
with a statement of how you do it or
that's the main
the difference between the q values that
are defined like that
but it's important so
how do we control the false discovery
rate
uh that depends on the distribution
of the different test statistics and the
correlation between them
remember we work with the pi so the
distribution of each
each uh test statistic by itself doesn't
matter
if the test statistics are independent
then the fdr is less by using this
method fdi is so equal to m naught over
n times q
m naught is the number of two ones so
this is always less or equal to one
if they independent and continuous
they're very surprising results we have
an exact equality
i mean exact inequality here that's the
original
result uh if they are positive dependent
then again we have inequality and i'll
talk about what is positive dependent in
a minute
everyone has its own positive dependent
concept of positive dependent
one of the weakest and even in the most
general way without any
constraint whatsoever you have the
result that the fdr is less or equal to
m naught over m
uh times q with one over plus a half and
so on and so forth
plus one over m which is approximately q
log n plus order
okay now what is positive dependence
positive dependence is the idea that if
you look at the test statistics x1 to xm
for any increasing set d what does it
mean increasing said the increasing set
d
is something that if you have a point in
d
another point which is uh which is
bigger than the original one in all of
its coordinates is also indeed
so so this is an increasing set
this is an increasing set and so on and
so forth
it contains if it contains the points it
contain everything above it
okay so for an increasing set and for
any
null hypothesis which is true if i
condition
only the value that it gets the
probability the x
is that x is in d is increasing in
s so the idea is if this is positive
dependence
and you look at at this region
but you condition on this one so you
look at actually this probability
then as you move to this one the
probability increases which is very
natural
idea of positive dependencies since they
go together
yeah i guess
the tests have the form
x i greater than some threshold so
there's some
assumption about the relationship
between the test statistic and
the p-value and the p-value so they have
to be monotone or like that
exactly that's the next context okay
good
good observation yeah i mean x is
positively dependent in any of the verb
senses
taking monotone or increasing or all
decreasing transformation in the
coordinates we leave the dependency the
same
so calculating p values just taking the
just taking the uh
probability under the null of that and
they're all monotone or taking the
probability in the other direction
people in another direction
this is also co-monotone so the moving
from
the test statistics to the p-value is
just satisfied
but and that's why it's important for me
not for two-sided
once i look at the absolute value of my
test statistics
once i look at both positive and
negative and want to decide
when is it significantly different in
either direction
then i run into trouble because they are
not
the the property doesn't keep itself the
prds property
however uh we're in good sense
because there are important cases
covered by prds
motivate multivariate normal with
positive correlation
is prds absolute studentized independent
normal
is prds even something like you take the
prds distribution and you divide it by a
common denominator
then it's not prds but but the theorem
still holds
monotone latent variable uh what is
monotone latent variable means it means
that you have some underlying variable
it's something that you use for instance
in testing you have some underlying
ability uh ability variable you don't
see it
but it's there given its value the
results are independent so the number of
answers
you will answer correctly once your
level of ability is known
will be independent conditionally this
is also satisfies this prds
so many situations in practice do cover
it
important cases not covered by the
theory is absolute studentized
correlated normal and pairwise
comparison
but by practice it is simulation partial
theoretical result and so on
and maybe with the hope of uh avousing
your
interest i'll i i did include this open
problem for two-sided tests
for those of you are interested in in
this kind of thing
um
results show that the worst case when
i'm doing two-sided which is not covered
by current theory
uh when the test statistics have
correlation one so you have the
the correlation the maximum correlation
is one asymptotically we know it holds i
mean that divorce situation is
independent and correlation one but this
is for finite situation we don't have
that
under this assumption the fdr can be
analytically worked out ensure that the
fdr is less so equal to q times
m not over m as before times one plus
but something that always assured that
this is less or equal to q
so we are still in the situation that it
is controlled but only
uh but the question is can it be proved
uh it's we have been waiting now for i
guess more than 15 years
with no success yeah i lost track what's
what's
m naught here m is the total number of
tests m naught is the number of two null
hypothesis
m is the number of hypotheses so this is
the proportion of two null hypothesis in
my
i don't know it for the time right until
now i don't know it
next two slides i will try to put a get
a hand on that
now this is a very recent result but
still waiting for that the other one
uh the other one is about
a pairwise comparisons and we have
all the uh empirical evidence from
simulation including took his own
simulation and with nice with jones and
so on
and um even though the correlation are
both positive and thirty
we are quite sure that this is the
situation and there is some theoretical
results by coutilli that if you do
each one separately it does control i
mean it's it's again in the air but we
can't
we don't have a clear food i certainly
don't hesitate
in using it either for the two-sided
normally distributed or for the pairwise
now look again at this one we always
have this factor in all of this we have
this factor this is a factor of
conservativeness
right i mean because this is always less
than equal to one and in fact it can be
much less than one so if we could put
our hand on that
then we would have a much better
procedure okay
because if m not was known we could use
exactly the same procedure
but just increase it by m over m mod
or equivalently work with q i over m
naught
rather than m and we will have exact
or we will use fdr oracle and they have
exact
control of the false discovery rate and
this is the essence of the adaptive
procedure
trying to estimate m naught or is it
sometimes called pi naught or p
naught uh from the entire ensemble of p
values and there's a whole i mean a
wrong
industry going on there dozens of paper
offering new methods uh
there are review papers at least four or
five review papers to review the
different uh
suggestions how to do it uh
i would like to point at uh at
an interesting one the graphical
approach of sweater and purple
that looked at this one this kind of
plot that we saw before and said wait a
minute
the large p values if they are if they
come from two null hypothesis
they have to have a uniform zero one
distribution and they should look like
the other statistics
from a uniform distribution well
the other statistic from uniform
distribution should lie on a line
well let's fit by eye a line like that
and get where it cuts here and get from
here the estimate of m naught
and it is it's working it's working
nicely and we have been able to prove
but
i'm not going to talk about that
because i want to emphasize
three options that have proven fdr
control
okay there are very few with proven fdr
control
first one is two stage procedure and it
goes like that
we'll use the bh procedure just a little
bit more conservatively instead of a
level q at a level q over one plus q
so just lower it a little bit okay and
then we would use the number rejected
in order to estimate the number of two
ones
by m minus the number rejected
okay so if i don't reject anything here
that's the first line of defense i stop
but otherwise i estimate it by m
minus r1 i still have to
be a little bit more conservative than
that i multiply that by one plus q
so just a little bit more because
remember here
in the number rejected there can hide a
few
true null hypothesis i'm a line cube
proportion key of non-electronic
hypothesis to high d
so and then use it again with q star
equals q m naught over m
and it has proven fdr control under
independence
what it means is what it means is that i
will
do it again but now a little bit more
conservative and i will stop here after
eight
then i'll do it again and
walk from here and now i stop uh for the
first time
at the 0.063 now that's wonders i did
even better
than the 0.05
but there's no limitation to that i can
decide that i don't want that and i want
to stop at the 0.05
because if something is taken out but
the point is that in terms of fdr
that's fine the second option
is the one originally suggested by story
and then modified by story taylor and
sigmund
take some predetermined lambda say
lambda equal to half and again use the
fact that uh
the the big b values give you
information about how many
true null hypothesis you have so simply
count how many big ones you have
number of pi bigger than this lambda
okay and take minus 1 minus that
oh sorry
that's the other way around this should
be less or equal because
n plus 1 minus that should be the number
of large b values
number of p-values above half plus one
divided by that and you have the an
estimator or how many you have over the
entire line
from zero to one rather than only from
lambda to one
let's go like this okay and
also an additional condition that pi has
to be less or equal to lambda if it's
half it's not a problem
and it also has proven fdr control under
independence
and some asymptotic control for weak
dependency as
well but the weak dependency is weak
in fact while this method is the most
powerful under independent of all
the ones that have proven to hold it it
fails to control
the fdr for all prds
and it's interesting to understand
why is that i'm not sure if i kept it
but the point is it's not
by little but the fdr may double
um just to give an idea
here i have that the estimated number is
six and i can go
all the way to 0.07 and this will be the
first one so i'm really
can gain a lot by this adaptive
procedure
but of course here there is a strong
those are the same animals there is a
strong
positive dependency between an animal
that uh
lingers a long time and it the distance
traveled is less i mean
clearly there's correlation because it's
the measured behavior of the same
animals
okay so we should uh this is a good time
to stop it's
coffee break time okay i will i will i
will stop in a minute and then uh
yeah let's talk in a minute so
i'll speak why dependency matter it
matters because under
correlation if i look at the first two
stage you see that the
the distribution of m not is uh is small
i mean the
the spread is small here we have 48 this
is the true
m naught and i'm conservatively above
that but not too big
this is the two stay this is the the
story uh
segmented at all that's uh as a wider
distribution but it's still fine
but if i'm going to correlation of 0.05
look at the spread of this
and too many times it is negative
and when it's positive uh it averages
out but not enough because of the spread
because of the
variance is uh positively
positively dependent in fact the worst
thing is you have here originally 64
hypothesis being tested
and unfortunately when people see that
the estimator is 80 or 19 they say well
that can't be
okay i mean i have only 64 ones how can
an estimator of m not b
80. so they put it down to 64. now doing
that
clearly destroys completely the
properties of these estimators
okay so i will um i will stop here as
suggested
and the next one will continue